bonsoir Jacques Weber alors dans ce
donjon là vous êtes scénariste
réalisateur acteur enfin c'est quand
même un gros travail
de l'autre c'est très marrant parce que
on va parler des autres acteurs il y a
Emmanuel Béart pas maquillé très nature
c'est ça que j'ai adoré c'est ça que
j'ai demandé c'est la première chose que
j'ai demandé j'ai dit si tu acceptes de
jouer ce jeu là en fond c'est elle a
accepté c'était magnifique quoi et
boujnaque et pas théâtre c'est aussi
rare oui non mais c'est vrai parce que
on s'attend toujours à quelque chose
d'un peu extériorisé de la part de
Michel est très généreux et là là il a
accepté aussi le jeu de quelque chose de
beaucoup plus
alors c'est pas le donjon de Molière
c'est d'après Molière c'est pas une
captation faut le dire aux gens parce
que pas une captation de la pièce
c'était un vrai film d'ailleurs un film
grand espace un peu western
moi je me suis plus inspiré de gens
comme John Ford
que des grands adaptateurs au théâtre au
cinéma c'est pas du tout moi je suis
content de ce que vous dites pas du tout
du théâtre filmer c'est une histoire qui
m'est venue en relisant mon Molière que
je connais bien bon je mets 200 fois
voilà c'est ça donc ça joue beaucoup
dans le travail et puis voilà puis on
fait un vrai film c'est le décor des
western spaghetti Almeria c'est un road
movie méditatif je sais pas qui a dit ça
mais c'est pas complètement faux alors
l'histoire bon je dis pas qu'on la
connaît mais enfin la trame de
l'histoire c'est Elvire joué par
Emmanuel Béart qui est séduite et
abandonné par Don Juan et puis les deux
frères qui pour ça qu'il pourchasse avec
la statue du Commandeur au passage fais
des choses qu'on a appris à l'école
alors la différence donc entre Molière
et vous c'est que Molière c'est presque
déjà au niveau de l'orthographe parce
que lui il écrit ça donc des OM et vous
donc des Owen alors expliquez-nous la
différence parce que le don des Owen
rejoint le donjon espagnol d'où il vient
de sa terre d'origine et que je pensais
que vu l'adaptation très libre que j'en
ai fait fallait plus revenir au mythe
qu'aux personnages spécifiques
alors Don Juan l'histoire de Don Juan
c'est quoi au début c'est tire
avec les 110 kg pour bébé la robe bleue
les cheveux longs on se dit c'est pas
l'image mais c'est pas l'image
effectivement parce que je me disais que
la séduction essentielle ne vient pas de
l'image convenu du Corot de choses là
cette fonction c'est peut-être peut-être
parfaitement authentique et d'interroger
le monde donc voilà moi c'est c'est ça
que j'ai voulu donner immédiatement 400
immédiatement l'image du bel homme qu'on
m'a d'ailleurs souvent donné à une
époque et puis et puis qu'on donne
souvent donjon et qui enlève un peu de
l'Intérieur
disons donc en fait le vrai donjon c'est
un mec sort la loi quoi c'est pas du
tout le mec qui drague c'est un rebelle
c'est un alors évidemment il
collectionne les femmes mais mais
méchamment quoi
il fait jouer le langage devant elle il
leur dit regardez avec les mots ce qu'on
peut faire et ce qui est très beau dans
dans le film c'est l'opposition avec
avec Sganarelle qui lui qui lui marmonne
ne sait pas trop parler même pas
s'exprimer et il y a une des choses que
dit donjon c'est avec 100 langages on ne
peut rien [ __ ] et sans et c'est le
langage qui est l'inventeur du sentiment
quoi on fait tout est du langage le tout
il est séduire leur premier temps le
mariage il est maritimes comme on dit
après c'est un peu feignant après le
braquage si tu es belle tu as de beaux
yeux on se parle ok au revoir voilà
alors il est libre hein on sait pas
enfin c'est pas où il va mais on sait
qu'il y a on sait qu'il y va aussi
d'ailleurs
au début du film elle peut le petit
garçon à qui dit c'est où le c'est il
demande une route alors garçon lui dit
c'est tout droit donc le film commence
comme ça se termine par où faut-il aller
c'est exactement ce que j'ai voulu
c'est assez étonnant c'est la portée du
film c'est ça c'est sa route entre ces
deux phrases il y a tout le film j'ai
changé
la place de la scène du pauvre à cause
de ça ce que je trouvais ça vachement
bien de commencer un film en disant
c'est où notre
cheminée
enfin il lui demande de jurer tout le
personnage est déjà contenu là dedans si
tu jures
voilà alors c'est la liberté en fait
quoi c'est c'est le film est aussi un
libertin dans le sens qui qui vous
laisse libre de l'interpréter comme vous
voulez moi je raconte une histoire une
légende il laisse les gens libres de
l'interpréter et c'est ça qui peut
déconcerter c'est ça qui me fait très
plaisir
parce qu'il y avait justement comme vous
disiez de faire des problèmes après la
censure de Tartuffe donc mais lui il a
eu des soucis avec ça aussi parce que il
a été obligé de se censurer lui-même
d'abord le lendemain alors vous savez
que c'est très marrant parce que cette
pièce qui est celle d'un API a été créé
un dimanche le lendemain le lundi on
coupait la scène du pauvre justement
cette scène du parjure on demande un
enfant de ce parjurer et puis après 15
jours après on abandonne les
représentations et après la pièce
disparaît elle ne apparaît dans la forme
que vous connaissez maintenant qu'en
1850 ou 60 avant c'était une pièce en
verre de Thomas Corneille et puis c'est
vraiment c'est avec Jouvet qu'elle
revient complètement à la mode
maintenant qu'elle est représentée
énormément de fois mais c'est vrai quand
on quand on regarde votre film ou quand
on regarde la pièce telle qu'elle est
jouée en ce moment au théâtre c'était
quand même drôlement en avance pour
c'est déjà ça annoncé la révolution ça a
annoncé
en avance dans le sens que faire parler
un athé pendant deux heures devant un
siècle ou la séparation du siège du
Saint Siège de l'été n'est pas encore
prononcé c'est quand même quelque chose
il est rationnel il est déjà très
lumière quoi un moment dans le film
enfin j'imagine que ça c'est dans la
pièce il dit moi je crois qu'un truc
c'est de 34 rue ce qui nous touche
vraiment c'est que c'est un homme qui a
le le bon si on parle simplement le
culot de d'interroger de de d'interroger
le sacré d'interroger la mort de dire je
vais l'amorcer quoi je vais au delà je
vais aller encore plus loin que la mort
c'est tout ça qui fait le fondement du
mythe de Don Juan et puis ce plaidoyer
pour le désir absolu pour la jouissance
du moment présent tout ça ça nous ramène
à nos tendances primitives c'est c'est
tout ce qui nous anime alors c'est un
film je le dis vraiment je vous l'ai dit
tout à l'heure quand je vous ai vu en
arrivant je veux dire ce qu'il m'a plus
étonné c'est pas que vous arriviez à
jouer donjons parce que vous avez déjà
joué 200 fois plus vous allez jouer
beaucoup me lire c'est un très bon
acteur de théâtre mais c'est la
réalisation c'est à dire il y a deux
scènes notamment qui m'ont beaucoup
impressionné il y a celle de où le la
statue du Commandeur arrive sur la
rivière qui est très très belle on
dirait magnifique et puis il y a la
scène de l'enterrement
qui est vraiment en durée du busuel
enfin j'en parle avec Elisabeth c'est
elle qui me disait ça me disant on
dirait du bus numéro
remarqué elle avait remarqué c'est c'est
deux scènes quoi qui sont vraiment très
bien réalisés bravo parce que c'est
votre premier film quoi complètement
j'ai regardé l'interview parce que je
savais que vous venez aujourd'hui et
vous me disiez moi je vais faire un film
je vous ai dit le cinéma vous a un peu
délaissé une grande carrière au théâtre
il me dit je vais faire un film mais ce
qui est marrant c'est qu'avant c'était
abstrait ça a été très longtemps après
donc c'est pas très intéressant tout le
monde a envie de faire son film quelque
part et puis d'un seul coup du jour au
lendemain je sais pas ça m'a pris la
gorge j'ai dit bon il faut que je fasse
et c'était tout de suite dans le genre
j'ai même pas réfléchi une minute et
c'est un film qui qui chiffre sont bons
c'est un film qui a coûté 32 millions ce
qui est pas énorme par rapport au budget
qu'on voit aujourd'hui pour un film qui
est quand même
qui vous écoutiez des disques cadets si
vous êtes endiez du lin et je vais vous
avez entendu à ce moment-là dans juin en
disque ça fait partie des fait partie
des choses qui vous ont oui en effet
j'ai entendu un enregistrement avec Jean
Vilar et Daniel Sorano c'était
absolument magnifique donc ça vient de
loin cette affaire parce qu'à l'époque
je sais pas vous aviez quoi au cœur
vaillant 7 ans non si oui j'avais 8 ans
oui ça a commencé très jeune
marqué aussi par l'avare vous allez voir
votre grand-mère avec votre grand-mère
vous étiez voir chamara dans la victoire
j'essaie de vous la question que je
voudrais vous poser c'est est-ce que
vous croyez que dans le métier d'acteur
est-ce que le mimétisme est important
parce que finalement vous avez écouté
ces disques que vous aviez les plus
grands acteurs ensuite vous allez voir
shamara vous vous avez beaucoup vous
êtes beaucoup inspiré de brasseurs qui
lui-même s'inspirait de béry d'ailleurs
est-ce que le mimétisme est une on le
dit jamais ça moi je crois qu'il faut
répondre personnellement
et puis Malraux parlait de de limitation
dans l'art que tout tout premier gestes
de l'art était toujours une imitation et
ça c'est redit d'autres façons mais
toujours oui moi je crois que c'est
évident pendant moi j'ai été très marqué
par brasseur je jouais un peu comme ça
je faisais les mêmes cerise vous disiez
voilà j'ai joué une fois avec bouquet je
trouvais tellement génial que le
lendemain je jouais un peu comme ça
comme chef bouquet quand j'écoutais les
disques de jouvais je parlais un peu
comme ça enfin bon moi en tout cas ça
concerne peut-être pas les autres mais
j'ai été tellement inhibé
des acteurs c'était la merveilleuse
tentative la thèse de de d'alarinais
dans Mon oncle d'Amérique la relation
entre Gabin et Gérard Depardieu c'était
c'est magnifique c'est c'est vrai oui
dites-moi
Marca brut on a fait un débat ici
là-dessus sur le fait qu'il y avait plus
d'auteur français au théâtre enfin etc
un grand papier de enfin grand papier
qui était remarqué en tous les cas de
marque abri dans le Figaro non je crois
qu'il y a plus les conditions d'accueil
accepter les accueillir ce qui est
complètement différent puisque en deux
mots les auteurs contemporains ne
peuvent être joué la plupart du temps
dans les subventionnés qui peuvent
prendre des risques et ce sont des
périodes trop court pour qu'il soit vu
par un grand public
mais j'affirme enfin on le sait il y a
des grands des grands auteurs nouveaux
déjà reconnu il y en a d'autres à venir
qui sont tout à fait exceptionnels et
importants tant pour le théâtre que pour
l'écriture cinématographique la santé
comment ça va parce que c'était un peu
vous êtes un peu hypocondriaque je
pouvais pas dormir dans une maison vide
c'est vrai vous êtes un peu vous êtes un
Vidal ambulant vos copain vous appelle
le Vidal en vidéo
comme j'ai des angoisses à cause de
mercredi c'est la sortie je te
confondent mes angoisses avec des
problèmes cardiologiques donc sans doute
aller revoir le cardiologue pendant tous
les cas moi je le dis au téléspectateurs
j'ai vu le film on s'emmerde pas faut le
dire parce que quand même c'est un
classique au départ donc c'est du vrai
cinnage quoi c'est pas du théâtre filmé
ça bouge boujna excellent moi je
recommande aux gens d'y aller ça me fait
plaisir alors avant de vous quitter je
vais montrer deux trois trucs donc il y
a des Sénart d'abord qui est que vous
avez édité hein c'est le jack Weber
adapté par Jean-Marie la clavetti hein
il y a un livre de Christian Biette sur
découverte voilà ce don Juan il y a le
donjon de Molière c'est foliothéâtre et
puis LCD de la bande originale alors
Bruno coulait hein qui a fait la musique
c'est le fils de Yvon Marie je crois que
je crois je suis pas sûr de la publicité
dans un journal professionnel de la pub
en disant il était photographié avec une
avec une torche il disait mon premier
cadeau bonus c'est ma porte son père
était très rigolo
merci beaucoup merci et à très bientôt
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu